our questions for giannis
uh lance allen
honest i know it's tough to to swallow
and stomach but just take us through
you know that last play and when you
heard the whistle were you just in
disbelief
uh i haven't seen the play i gotta go
watch the play again
you know trying to make it tough for
jimmy
um you know the ref said that there was
contact there
uh maybe there was i gotta watch the
play
you know it is what it is um
try to go test the shot but
after the refs called that foul you know
the the camera showed you sitting
uh you know courtside just what's going
through your mind
as you're sitting there and they're
looking at the the replay
i'm just trying to see if it's uh before
the time was over
or after uh just trying to wait for the
decision that the
the refs going to take um
just thinking through the play you know
what happened because you know when you
have so much adrenaline
you just act um so yeah that was good
through my mind
malika go ahead i know you haven't
watched the play yet but when you do
watch it back
are you looking at it to see okay is
there a different way i could manipulate
my body to avoid that are you looking at
to see if you
agree with the call like what's the
thought there no the call is already
made
so i mean looking at the place just
you know how can i you know not put
myself in a situation like that
i feel like uh personally it was that i
play i've done this
uh multiple times in my career um
you know when the guy's dribbling and
he's getting his rhythm uh
going like he got four seconds he's not
gonna pass the ball he's gonna shoot the
ball
so yeah i'm just going look at the place
if it was that i play
eric name
obviously you guys kind of had that
flurry late to tie the game up and get
back into it but
it's felt like in the middle of the
fourth quarter there was turnovers kind
of sloppy play how do you guys try to
find something
easier offensively it feels like
everything you have to work for
yeah i think it's the playoffs so
obviously miami is a great defensive
team
you know play hard to make it hard for
us we try to make it hard for them
and you know it's not gonna be easy and
you gotta
you know grind through it you gotta play
hard you gotta scream screen hard you
gotta roll hard
you gotta come out of the screen hard
you know and you know when you get tired
you get sloppy you
you know tour numbers happen so
obviously we just gotta
just gotta do it hard whatever we do
downstairs we gotta do it hard and
uh hopefully we can take care of the
ball and um
you know stephen watson
hey giannis i remember after you played
the heat at the end of
the regular season inside the bubble and
i asked you if you felt like this team
presented the biggest challenge to you
guys in the east
and you said it was about us it was
about the bucks and how you guys
handle yourselves the way that you guys
have played two games in this series
you're now one and four against the heat
this year
do you still feel like it's about you or
do you feel like this team has presented
a larger challenge than you anticipated
it's about us
it's always going to be about us you
know uh
that's that's why we practice you know
that's why we go through our game plan
that's why we gotta come out and play
harder that's why we gotta make more
shots it's always gonna be all about us
you know it's it's not about uh what the
other team is gonna do you know might be
the miami hit now
um next round might be a different team
next year might be different teams
going to be about us you know how can we
get better how can we not repeat the
same mistakes
you know how can we not uh down the
stretch make turnovers you know how can
we create easier said it's always going
to be about us
it's never going to be about you know
that team every plane
time for two more let's go to dan wakey
giannis uh situations this year haven't
really called for you to have to go
and play more than 40 minutes is that
something
now down 02 that you feel like you need
to put your hand up and say
i'm good to go as long as i need to be
on the court
i'm going to do whatever coach dubai
tells me to do
that's what i'll be doing all year
obviously i'll have to play 48 minutes
but you know he sees the game he coaches
the game
so he's going to do whatever he tells
him to do
and last one to vince goodwill
jonas just seems like whenever you're
you're playing against the heat
you have like 10 eyes on you like
they're you're always facing
five defenders do you is there something
to getting you the ball in different
positions to make it a little bit
easier on you so you don't have to see
five guys in front of you
obviously you know um trying to run more
you know try to get myself in the corner
just try to give
give the defenders different looks you
know my teammates have been helping me
with that
you know um find them in different uh
areas on the court uh but at the end of
the day i just gotta keep being
aggressive no matter where i'm
on the court i gotta keep being
aggressive
thank you janice